plus de 18 mille cinq cents visiteurs
ont foulé les allées du marché de noël
ini montain organisée à la ferme du
manet pour cette 25e édition une grande
roue a été installée et 130 exposants
étaient présents convivialité
voilà une préparation de période de
fêtes et
un esprit familial tous les ans c'est un
petit rituel qu'on se fait on viole ce
programme petit vin chaud est un très
bon produit
un producteur qu'on vient voir depuis
quelques années de foie gras sur le
marché et puis des jolis petits bijoux
aussi pour faire des
les commande au père noël des artisans
ont présenté leurs produits c'est le cas
de stéphanie siégel setting monteyne
fabrique des savons à partir de produits
naturels et biologiques
c'est son cinquième marché de noël c'est
très convivial c'est très agréable de
venir participer à ce marché de noël
parce que
une très bonne ambiance les gens
viennent vraiment dans l'esprit
d'acheter leurs petits cadeaux de noël
plusieurs producteurs venus de toute la
france proposent leur gourmandise
emile et marcel viennent depuis 25 ans
ils font chaque année 850 km pour vendre
le produit phare des fêtes de fin
d'année le foie gras
d'abord il est très bien accueillie par
par la ville et par tout le monde et
puis en viennent donc chaque fois chaque
parce que nous avons pas mal de clients
sur la région parisienne
c'est une satisfaction les clients les
gens sont tellement contents que nous on
est ravi de ce succès et ça nous donne
vraiment envie de continuer pour les
années futures
les organisateurs souhaitent s'appuyer
sur le succès de cette année pour la
prochaine édition l'an dernier ce marché
de noël avait attiré 15 mille visiteurs